the blue light Cavs show special guest
I've interviewed him before but never on
camera
by the way shout out to Bryson tiller
he's in the building man yes sir yes sir
the legend okay I gotta say man um why
are you doing stuff on camera now
because before you were not doing camera
stuff like I feel like it was kind of
like when you first came out like the
Trap Soul days you kind of were keeping
a mysterious profile yeah like I
remember I interviewed you on the bus
but it was like No cameras and that was
kind of like the thing where it's like
yo we we hear the interviews like but
Bryson you're kind of very like
you kind of you were you still you're
pretty low-key dude in general right
yeah and I was just new to it I didn't
want to you know be all over the
Internet you know what I mean it was
just like a thing for me I just was just
very new to everything so I was just
kind of like trying to take my time not
just be rushed into it you know that's
fair do you feel like um you're kind of
like
the music industry is a very finicky
business it's kind of like even just
just the entertainment industry in
general you kind of Splash under the
scene in such a meteoric way and so fast
um was it like hard to adjust to it in
such a quick way you think that that's
yeah absolutely yeah it was a lot a lot
to adjust to like
it was like I always tell who do I give
this analogy to but I say it all the
time it's like taking up
a lion that was raised in inside the
house and then just put them in a jungle
you know what I'm saying for the right
time he's still lying but you know it's
just like weird out here you know yeah
that was going on 100 man a hunt for
food